dur oui moi j'appelle palombes à machin
dit
voilà deux j'ai trouvé ça d'un d'un
irrespect incroyable
alors juste pour lui dire ce que moi
j'ai vu j'ai pas l'habitude d'étaler ma
science et et voilà et de donner mon cv
juste pour vous dire voilà j'ai un
diplôme j'ai une maîtrise de philosophie
gpo callikan j10
j'ai un diplôme d photojournalisme j'ai
une formation hec à hec j'ai également
je gère pratiquement 60 personnes dans
mes services je gère des budgets à
plusieurs millions d'euros donc venir me
faire traiter comme si j'étais là la
moindre des moins que rien par quelqu'un
qui a commencé sa carrière dans premiers
baisers et sont rusés
[Applaudissements]
excusez mais franchement j'aime ça
j'ai commencé ma carrière à la marche du
siècle et au figaro littéraire donc
voilà alors je prêtais ce que je sois
content dépenses
je sais que tu en voilà je dirige des
magazines people et j'en suis très fier
mais je le répète je ne parle pas au nom
de mes journalistes people je voudrais
juste vous rappeler géré a dit que quand
je viens parler du people vous êtes
l'une des premières à me demander tous
les petits potins derrière en coulisses
alors votre hypocrisie des médecins oui
mais elle a le droit d'aimer ça et moi
aussi j'aime ça intéresse mais deux là
mais je ne suis pas loin de là à
justifier mon incapacité à parler de
sujets qui me touche parce que je me
renseigne je trouve ça immonde et puis
alors pour finir et après je laisserais
parler géraldine elle nous a quand même
parlé du professeur j me mohamed un
super référence
et moi d'accord mais moi je vais aussi
voir des gens savent où l'autre qu'on
peut tuer je vais également voir des des
professeurs comme le laurent comme
laurent perreau phéromones qui est à
l'hôpital cochin je suis également
beaucoup gérard kernec je vois aussi
l'épidémie pdi pardon épidémiologiste de
l'inserm
laurent toubiana je voudrais juste
rappeler quand même que monsieur comment
il s'appelle jimmy mohamed en mars 2021
a dit que le vaccin astrazeneca sur
européen tueur repas était fiable et
efficace il était interdit dans
énormément de
jeu là d'accord mais bon c'est défi
revenant fait référence à l d'honorer
une grande effectivement spécialistes
scientifiques comme chacun sait voilà et
qui se permet de dénigrer des gens comme
moi qui ne sont pas dans le temps voilà
dans le discours unique et qui disent
que voilà on peut avoir aussi une
politique sanitaire différentes je
trouve ça honteux est ce que vous avez
dit à guillaume genton c'est honteux
quand elle a commencé à lui dire à ben
j'espère que tu respecte la loi on
parlera de ça après si vous voulez mais
ça aussi j'ai trouvé pas mal dans mes
débuts c'est quoi le célèbre auelua
diaby j'espère que tu respecte la loi
parce que pour moi tu es quelqu'un de
très dangereux alors moi je voudrais
quand même juste lui rappeler que on a
un président qui a quand même dit que
ces lois étaient faites pour emmerder
des non vaccinés voilà donc très
clairement donc excusez moi mais l'état
de droit
c'était pas la reverb et puis ce qui
vous énerve ses appels
c'est à dire que l on
retient les questions que vous soyez
convaincus st que vous soyez un peu
d'immigrés c'est ça il en fait géraldine
symbolise voilà ce qu'est ce que vous
n'aimez pas parce qu'on est dénigré par
d'autres personnels alors qu'ils sont de
même ne bisse gérald ici ça m est sinon
mais les toits des parents d'élèves y un
instant vous nous parlez balade voilà
systématiquement quand quand voilà on
dit des choses différentes on est soit
complotistes né soit beauty sonné soit
facho mais excusez moi aujourd'hui
l'addition mais l'a pas dit ça mais le
dénigrement avec laquelle elle a parlé
hier soir celle des avocats c'était
juste voilà serait dédaigneux et
méprisant donc donc voilà donc je vois
là et en plus pour le coup je tiens à
lui dire moi c'était c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie
[Rires]
fier que je pouvais pour l'heure
apathique et puis en fait bas je me
rends compte que voilà alors à tenter
la traversée vrai vous êtes déçu parlera
du mali totalement ou totalement vous
verrez il y avait une indication quand
même vrai je m'en fous d'elle
ça vous appelez c'est quand même quand
elles vous ça m'a blessée parce que
parce que voilà c'est c'était une façon
de me dénigrer et de me faire passer
pour une abouti qui voit là je suis
alors je suis désolé je suis venu avec
mes filles parce qu'en plus j'ai
travaillé le dossier je me suis
documenté je pars
platement d éviter le mot de travailler
dans cette équipe c'est vrai c'est un
gros alors bon alors beaucoup de choses
ont été dites
d'abord premier baiser j'en suis très
fier parce que ça me permettait de payer
mes études tant mieux ensuite moi j'ai
été caissière aussi pour payer moi là
donc il ya pas de sot métier de pain
pour payer ses études ensuite le propre
de tpm p vous venez souvent ici c'est
des débats animés on est en direct alors
on est en colère on s'invective on n'est
pas d'accord on est d'accord voilà c'est
le sel c'est l'adn c'est la force de
cette émission et c'est pour ça qu'on
aime la faire et je trouve que c'est un
espace de liberté sans précédent et je
trouve qu'on a beaucoup de chance voilà
vous avez l'habitude de venir ici dans
cette émission par rapport à public vous
nous parlez de arie habitants de la
grossesse de la copine de zemmour de
ppda ils ne sont pas là et pourtant vous
parler d'eux ça vous dérange pas et est
ensuite devenu non pelées ça me dérange
pas non mais non mais moi ça me
rappelait ce que vous ça vous avez là je
parle de vous quand vous n'étiez pas là
et l'autre jour pour la première fois
vous venez en tant que citoyenne engagée
vous l'avez dit je crois à côté de haut
niveau lui d'ailleurs qui étaient là ce
soir là est donc là vous étiez plutôt
dans voilà votre manière de concevoir
cette crise sanitaire comment elle était
gérée le vaccin le pass vaccinale pour
et contre voilà donc moi je vous écoute
je suis pas d'accord avec vous mais je
ne suis pas là pour vous convainc de la
même manière que je ne suis pas d'accord
avec des emballages vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec moi mais je ne suis pas là
pour vous convaincre et hier quand j'ai
parlé de vous en fait j'ai de la même
manière qu'on dit on n'est pas d'accord
avec macro on n'est pas d'accord avec
veron j'ai dit je suis pas d'accord avec
enfin quand je suis malade je vais pas
demander à palombes away division enfin
il y avait absolument rien de la bonne
façon d'aller vous allez c'est pas
l'impression que j'ai eue chemin tu vois
là bas c'était pour moi c'était très
très méprisant mais
je suis pas du tout citoyenne et vous
avez là une souci toilettes
aux conditions mais je n'ai pas tout
honneur absolue voilà
mais on n'avait pas donc elle fait
depuis le début la propagande pour aller
excepté un
médecin je suis venu apporter et puis
surtout je tiens à vous dire que le pass
vaccinale c'est juste honteux de mettre
des citoyens qui ne refusent de se faire
vacciner au ban de la société c'est
juste
mais ça dans ma vie non non moi mais je
suis venu répondre à ça qu'est-ce que
vous l'aurez pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya
rien de mieux c'est évidemment pas
fantastique mais ya rien de mieux
aujourd'hui pour pour eux alors moi je
vais lui répondre mais vous alors le
conseil de l'europe dans sa valise
dansaert excusez moi parce qu'à
apprendre à jouer intello et ça fait
chier tous les bons faut quand même le
dire cela dit vous savez donc dans sa
résolution du 27 janvier 2021 a demandé
ce que la vaccination ne soit pas
obligatoire et qu'aucun citoyen ne doit
subir deux ans et sociales et politiques
pour se faire vacciner que le conseil
d'europe voilà donc pas eu leur mi mai
mais reste élections alors vous allez
vous les élites ouailles à m oui j'ai
encore bien aujourd'hui moi en tant que
citoyenne ben déjà d'une femme pose des
problèmes dans mon travail parce que
voilà je ne peux plus aller au
restaurant faire des rendez vous etc je
ne peux plus participer à des événements
ça quand tu sais pourtant que ce soit
alors si c'est les gens qui sont
vaccinées positifs peuvent prendre le
train mais des gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés et négatifs ne peuvent pas le
prendre c'est notre premier ministre qui
l'a dit nous avons quand même des
soignants il ya 15000 soignants qui ont
été virés parce qu'ils ont refusé la
vaccination
alors qu'aujourd'hui on se rappelle des
soignants qui sont posées sites locaux
vides que de soigner les gens
moi je vous dis juste un peu de logique
un peu de prudence et un peu aussi voilà
2 2 social est doué et arrêtons